I probably wouldn't listen to who is
this these guys way these guys look 30
right now I'm like so one direction so
I'm a one directional I don't know any
of their names my knees were like
probably like the biggest like stars of
like the time my mom was all over this
this reminds me of one direction right
here but maybe One Direction stole this
from them I actually like the song it's
a good song is catchy and the guy in the
front is super cute we should like bring
your helmet I know the denim on denim on
denim on denim does not come back yeah I
hope it never does
I think these guys set the tone for a
lot of these boy bands isn't Justin
Timberlake in this band Justin
Timberlake is my favorite you are a
major iron Beast I never thought of this
I feel like they're dancing is kind of
better
this one's my jam their hearts being tan
but they're like at this local gym
there's more like material things being
shown off in music videos now these days
I could totally see myself being a
fangirl
Oh supermodel I feel like this is like a
wedding song
I actually pretty good I like it I like
love the song sounds very hard but oh
here comes the course oh I know the song
I do I swear I will get on one bended
knee I would stand outside your house in
the pouring rain this would never be
rated today because it's like so good
yeah they don't play this stuff anymore
nowadays they talk about acid tits there
this song they're actually talking about
like loving a girl they're just like is
a music like this anymore but I wish
there was he was in 98 degrees I can't
think of a single person ittle bit uh
Jessica flippin ex-husband Michael che
I've heard of him but I guess I didn't
realize he was in a band
I don't know he's saying why is
everybody's pants so baggy even these
shirts so nineties nobody wears like
that anymore wear little earrings it's a
cute song but
[Music]
I've never heard of Hanson you have it
oh my gosh they're so young I think
they're our brothers oh that's awesome I
don't get it I don't know what's going
on but they would like to having a good
time yeah this might be my favorite
music video so far like this looks like
a lot of fun it's kind of cute I mean
where are their parents and I'm pretty
sure like once they hit puberty and
those voices drop oh yeah yeah their
money went you definitely heard of the
Backstreet Boys this guy looks like
Aaron Carter Yeah right
oh I've googled him recently and he does
not look bad that like drum beat of like
the boy bands like it's all the same I
love the outfits though like the girls
outfits
those are Spice Girls I think I'm more
of a new kids on the block but actually
I kind of liked this song better so I'm
really conflicted right now
we know this they play this at every
graduation it would be faster now but I
got some good voices
oh he's into it you can see the soul
coming out of his neck like they saw
vulnerability you know digging the
coordinated outfits their fashion is
though and I like it I know my songs
like this I could cry do you think
children to listen to this rather than
like what's playing now yeah so true we
need more than any more of this the 90s
boy bands overall we're like great I
didn't know a lot about 90's boy bands
to watching this but if I grew up back
in the day I feel like I'd be really
into it
I do wish that music videos now we're
like 90s music videos or at least the
songs were like 90 songs because
everything is so smooth sounding and
just chill and not so much like of the
derogatory lyrics they definitely
catered and dedicated their songs to
girls making girls feel good about
themselves they'll definitely be
remembered forever
[Music]